CS2 is real and it is about to change
everything look at this this is exactly
what I'm talking about it yes
yes that's what we're talking about it's
got better graphics sleeker skins and
smokes that have the potential to
reshape the entire game
but valve has also promised something
that CS players have been begging for
for years better servers dude
already it feels terrible yeah yeah yeah
yeah we can't I mean we're done that's
it valve's promise of improved servers
with the launch of CS2 seems too good to
be true I don't press the 64 tick or
whatever fake tick whatever they came up
with I don't trust that [__] whatever
they're doing is something Shady but
[Music]
or better
really save counter-strike's god-awful
match me
[Applause]
spring is finally here so before we get
into the video and start talking about
CS2 I want to remind you all that we
have merch with the new season upon us
perhaps it's time to upgrade your
wardrobe just like valve allegedly
upgraded their servers head to
shop.thescore.com and click on our
Esports collection to check it out okay
so it is no secret that CS go
matchmaking can be
pretty bad from the obvious aimboters to
the toxic Griefers there are plenty of
people who make it their mission to ruin
the experience for everyone for casual
players this is obviously very
frustrating but even if you do manage to
find a match that does not have any of
these cringe ass cretans there is still
one problem that haunts CS go to its
very core
the base servers are 64 tick
now if you're wondering what tick rate
is Colton did a pretty comprehensive
breakdown in our video about ping back
in 2021 but to put it simply tick rate
refers to the number of times that the
server processes incoming information
each second things like player locations
and bullet trajectory are updated in
accordance with tick rate and since 128
tick servers are simulating the in-game
physics more times per second some
weapons are slightly more accurate and
smokes actually travel further which is
why most of the time you need different
smokes for 64 tick and 128 tick now
there are certainly ways to play the
game on higher tick rate servers most
notably face it faceit has its own 1286
servers a working anti-cheat and an ELO
system that allows you to work your way
up the ranks all things that CS go
doesn't really have but for ninety
percent of the player base
it's just not practical they just want
to load up the game hop into matchmaking
and not have to worry about which smoke
lineup to use whether their shots will
register or if they're going to get
mowed down by a cheater not to mention
that some face it features like vetoing
Maps or picking which servers you can
play are locked behind a subscription it
doesn't help that when the vowel beta
launched back in April of 2020 Riot had
already solved many of these problems
players could simply load up matchmaking
and play on 1286 servers with a
functioning anti-cheat from the get-go
but for CS frogs like myself this was
actually a good thing this put pressure
on valve to finally update
counter-strike's infrastructure
of course it took them three years to do
it but hey
better late than never last month
Counter-Strike 2 was officially
announced it's coming with updated
lighting effects and insane smoke
grenade physics and most importantly
valve finally addressed the server
issues in previous versions of
Counter-Strike the game only evaluated
moving and shooting in discrete time
intervals or ticks and time between
those ticks didn't exist for the most
part the experience was seamless but
sometimes those milliseconds between
click and tick could be the difference
between Landing or missing your shot
that's why with Counter-Strike 2 we're
introducing subtic updates now the tip
rate no longer matters for moving and
shooting so the server will know the
exact moment you fired your shot jumped
your jump or peaked your pee and the
server will calculate your precise
actions between ticks so what you see is
what you get you'll notice that they
didn't say 128 tick they said subatic
now according to valve that's even
better but some players are still
skeptical about it just remove tick rate
just remove tick rate if they don't know
tick rate exists they think it's all the
same
genius bro they're still trying to save
money looks like
but I respect they're doing something so
it's good it's good whatever I mean I
mean it could be bad it could be
terrible actually it could be terrible
once they eventually got their hands on
cs2's limited play test players like
Tariq and shroud didn't exactly see much
of an improvement shooting feels pretty
pure so far
from the first version of the game
a little off that shooting feels good I
don't trust the 64 tick or whatever fake
tick whatever they came up with I don't
trust that [__] now although was mostly
trolling and some people think the
Shroud was coping for being slightly
washed hey I didn't say it his chat did
there were definitely some more credible
names who thought that cs2's tick rate
didn't quite feel up to par the Estonian
goat drops even posted in a 1.6 KZ Forum
that sub tick rate doesn't feel as good
as described there's obviously a
difference between 64 and 128 it is the
only thing which feels bad maybe it can
be tweaked it's more like 64 than 128.
Loba in particular was
well
[__] all over it CS2 sucks dick we
reached out to valve hoping that they
would share some info with us about how
subtik updates work
as expected
they didn't respond honestly honestly I
think I'd have a better chance at
getting in contact with Joe Biden than
someone at valve I'll need an effective
strategy to mobilize true International
pressure that being said some members of
the community like Mr Maxim have taken
matters into their own hands and are
speculating that the large packet size
is being sent from cs2's servers imply
that they are in fact 64 tick because
the packet is so large it needs to be
split into a secondary packet that is
sent immediately after the first one
which could explain why the time between
the first and second one is so fast and
theoretically speaking if it could send
the packets without splitting them
assuming that's what's happening we
would be seeing 64 packets per second
and the average millisecond would double
this means it would look more like a 64
tick server this is why I think my
speculation from last video is probably
incorrect what feels more likely to be
true is that the server was running
closer to a 64-tick environment but
because the packets are so large they
needed to be split into two now for some
of you I know that all of this tick rate
talk is
putting you to sleep but I know somebody
who is frothing at the mouth to share
his thoughts with you all about valve's
new tech
isn't that right Colton and now the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about oh so you will listen to a
controller loving casual but only when
it's convenient for you I see how it is
thankfully the areas where Dimitri can
call himself the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about are narrow
enough that I don't think we have to
worry about him taking my job when valve
dropped they're moving beyond tick rate
video one thing in particular stuck out
to me this graphic right here as soon as
I saw that my computer nerd brain went
into overdrive trying to figure out how
the hell they would even do that so I'm
going to share with you my mildly
educated guesses since valve has been
pretty quiet on their cool new netcode
first things first the servers still
have a tick rate so to speak they aren't
just processing and sending in packets
at light speed because well that just
isn't how servers work so barring valve
having servers from the space future how
are they getting these subtic updates
that they're touting well my first guess
actually came straight from that graphic
I mentioned earlier when your PC sends
off the network packet with your inputs
to the valve server it's time stamped
thanks to your local game running its
simulation at the same tick rate as the
server so when two players inputs show
up the server can figure out which
happened first thanks to these
timestamps I know I know I'm
oversimplifying a lot but I'm not a
distributed systems developer and
statistically I'm here trying to explain
this to a lot of other non-developers
that's you guys in case that wasn't
clear essentially with this model even
if my inputs are faster than my
opponents if they both happen within
that same 1 64th or 128th of a second
that the server tick rate runs at then
they may as well have happened at the
same time but what if instead of being
time stamped by The Tick they happened
on these inputs were time stamped with
the millisecond they happened on then
even though the server doesn't process
them any faster it can node down to the
millisecond which player's inputs happen
first and calculate back in time through
the server tick to get the most accurate
simulation but of course it's not quite
as simple as it sounds as it turns out
synchronizing distributed clocks like
that is about as non-trivial as it gets
distributed systems designers try at all
costs to avoid designing anything that
relies on synchronized clocks across
machine whether valve has developed some
ingenious code to create a super
accurate millisecond synchronized clock
between players in the server or some
other method using complex math logical
clocks whatever
one thing is certain the packets that
your CS2 client is sending the server
are way bigger than they used to be
which makes me think that however
they're doing it valve servers are
getting a much more accurate picture of
the player's inputs and when they
happened until valve opens up more about
what's actually going on here everything
is just speculation but considering how
old and Incredibly difficult to work
with the Cs go source code is to say
nothing of the cost I can't imagine
valve we're super Keen to move all their
matchmaking servers to 128 tick so by my
best guess you're still playing on the
exact same servers as before and Mr
maxson's packet data seems to back that
up as valve managed to completely
revolutionize low tick rate net code
I guess time will tell and that was the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about all right look the Limited Test is
indeed very limited not many people
myself included have had the pleasure of
experiencing CS2 in all of its Glory
probably because I didn't spend the last
couple of years grinding matchmaking
or you know balance
what the [__] did I hear I thought I
heard one spawn bro [__] this [__]
when's CS3 coming out bro but thankfully
I do know one man who has one Jordan
nothing Gilbert we had the pleasure of
sitting down with Mr flashbang dance
himself to talk about his experience
with CS2 thus far my first impression
was hey I'm happy that it doesn't look
too crazy I'm happy it doesn't look too
different better looking brightness
colors vibrancy that stuff I'm just
hoping there's still a little bit of
muddiness in kind of the feeling of of
the mechanics but it doesn't feel as bad
as CS go did when it first came out I
don't know exactly where the clunkiness
is coming from that I'm feeling
um you know they have their new lossless
tick system that they claim and I don't
fully understand it yet but something
about it feels like we were joking that
it feels like 88 tick or something like
it feels a little better than 64 but
does it like we're not quite sure where
like the registration kind of felt good
shooting kind of felt good but then like
the spray and movement randomly it just
felt a little clunky especially the
movement you kind of catch yourself not
feeling not feeling fluid so there were
definitely some mixed feelings about CS2
especially when it comes to its sub tick
updates I'm still not exactly sure how
they work but there's definitely still a
lot of people out there who do not agree
that they make the game feel better that
being said there's no denying that
valve's CS2 announcements seriously lit
a fire under the Casual player base
since the release of cs2's Limited Test
CS goes player base has continued to
reach all-time highs and with a proper
functioning anti-cheat allegedly coming
with the new installment there's no
denying that valve are finally trying to
improve their game in a way that matters
the game is still in beta and there's
plenty of time for valve to make changes
before its official launch in the summer
but as long as valves stay true to their
prom and the servers actually feel
better that I can't wait to get my hands
on it
just like everybody else
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock